بواعث قلق جديده يتحدث عنها رئيس
بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو يقول ان
الدول الغربيه تخطط لشن حرب عالميه ثالثه
بحرائق نوويه وتحضر للهجوم على بلاده
داعيا الى بدء محادثات للتوصل الى تسويه
سلام في اوكرانيا
ثقوا في كلامي لم اخدعكم قط انهم يتاهبون
لغزو بيلاروسيا وتدمير دولتنا من المستحيل
هزيمه قوه نوويه اذا ادركت القياده
الروسيه ان الوضع يهدد بتفكيكها فستستخدم
اكثر الاسلحه رعبا وهذا لا يمكن السماح به
ابدل كاشينكو استعداده لاستقبال اسلحه
نوويه استراتيجيه روسيه على اراضيه ثم
تستعد موسكو لارسالها الى حليفتها ويستبعد
الكريم وقف عملياته العسكريه في اوكرانيا
ردا على الدعوه الى هدنه
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا لا شيء يتغير العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه مستمره لانها الطريق
الوحيده لتحقيق الاهداف التي حددتها
بلادنا اليوم
استبعد مسؤول اوكراني كبير اي وقف لاطلاق
النار خلال الحرب يتضمن بقاء القوات
الروسيه في الاراضي التي تحتلها الان في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]